hello this is another one of my dr
sather chalk and talk second series i'm
restarting it after having let it lay
fallow for a while
and the question that i'm beginning with
is one that was asked
of me by some of my students here at
marist
what is existentialism and
they originally asked it to me because
they were thinking about taking a class
in existentialism
and they want to know what's it all
about what is existentialist philosophy
and so
i thought that's a good good question
that's a hard one to answer
and so what i've got here on the board
are some common themes and some authors
i'm going to talk a little bit about
all of these
how they're connected to each other but
we're really just scratching the surface
and one of the things i want to point
out from the beginning
is that a lot of the authors that we now
identify as existentialists
either didn't know about that at the
time
or they rejected that that very title
after a while
some of them did embrace that
so
let's actually start with talking about
some of the equal authors
you notice we're beginning with certain
kierkegaard
some people have
said that that you can trace back
existentialism further you know and to
say blaise pascal and his passaise
there's a case to be made for that some
trace it back even further to saint
augustine and his emphasis on the
individual
and subjectivity
and exploring oneself in the confessions
and again there's something to that but
if we want to talk about it as an actual
movement of philosophy
it makes more sense to start it with
these 19th century thinkers
and then look at some of the 20th
century thinkers many of whom looked
back to these 19th century thinkers
as being sort of the beginnings of where
they got their
not necessarily all of their thought but
their impetus to thought
and of course these thinkers are not
arising out of an entire vacuum certain
kierkegaard studied philosophy very
extensively dostoyevsky knew his
philosophy very well nietzsche knew his
philosophy very well they they're
reacting to a lot of different movements
of thought and incorporating elements
from
thinkers before them they particularly
liked you know certain kicker guard for
example with plato and socrates
um dostoyevsky you know discussing all
sorts of different philosophical
positions
nature going back to the
greeks as well
kierkegaard is a very clearly early 19th
century thinker in denmark
he is a christian existentialist
you can say that there are theistic
existentialists so those who believe in
god in one form or another
and i don't have all of them up here and
another one that would be very good to
point out
would be
martin buber
is a clear example of jewish
existentialism
leo chest off sometimes
chest dog
great
russian
theistic thinker
which don't have enough room on the
board
anyway kierkegaard gets the ball rolling
um
kierkegaard writes
philosophy and theology treatises but
they are very
involved they involve they they are very
complex they have a lot of narrative and
a lot of structure to them that's coming
from literary
genres as well as just philosophical
genres dostoyevsky is kind of like
turning that on its head dostoevsky is
writing stories and novels
and in his stories of novels you're
going to find an awful lot of philosophy
being talked about being accepted
rejected assumed discussed uh debated
and so he fits in there as well
nietzsche
you know very important figure in
philosophy even down to the presence
perhaps overshadowing kierkegaard to a
certain extent
although i actually prefer kierkegaard
nietzsche myself
nietzsche
makes contributions of all different
sorts
very clearly an atheistic existentialist
kafka franz kafka
writes novels and short stories
and within his work the philosophy
is not quite so clearly
brought to the surface as it is with
dostoyevsky who has many of his
characters in fact talk about
philosophy but there is
a lot of philosophy laying in just under
the surface of how his works
martin heidegger now we're actually into
the 1920s and 30s and 40s
major
german philosopher of the last century a
phenomenologist actually rejected the
title existentialist but but it does fit
in in certain respects as we'll see when
we look at the themes
john paul stark another
french phenomenologist an existentialist
also a novelist a playwright
savannah gouvoir
um
who had a long time connection with with
jean-paul sartre
novelist herself
she actually ends up writing what
jean-paul sartre should have written
providing existentialism at least their
version of atheistic existentialism and
ethics in the ethics of ambiguity
also an important
contributor to feminist thought with her
book with second sex
gabriel marcel a christian
existentialist who again rejected the
title of existentialist preferred to be
called a
christian socratic
and then albert
another atheistic existentialist who was
for a while friends with john paul stark
who broke with him
over a number of different reasons
these are some of the major names
there's also many people who are not
represented on this list
talking about martin buber just as an
example
who camus actually credits with with
being a spur to his own thought
there's there's quite a few
novelists and playwrights who have been
called existentialist who even may have
you know taken on that that term that
title at certain times like hemingway
for example
or as recently as norman mailer mailer
writes pretty
pretty extensively about his
relationship with existentialism and
conceived of an american dream as an
existentialist novel
but
when you talk about existentialism in
the in terms of a course these are
usually the thinkers that we're looking
at the most close often times we don't
get to all of them
so what is existentialism in terms of
its essential ideas and central themes
if again you want to sort of pin
a label onto
a coherent
school of thought you know if you can
shoehorn all these people together it's
kind of difficult to do
i would say
and not everybody is in agreement with
me but i would say that these are the
really key critical themes
that
get to the heart of what existentialism
as an attitude as a philosophical
position or school of positions which
would comprise
and
the first thing we have to talk about is
of course existence
sartre very famously says
that human beings
first exist and then
have an essence we're unlike other
beings
in that the very notion of what
a human being is is one of the things we
have to grapple with and he's not you
know making that up by himself we're
coming up with that as a totally novel
thing martin heidegger is saying
something similar
and you can see elements of that
enunciated in you know various parts of
nietzsche kierkegaard and dostoevsky the
question of what is a human being but
this is not a uniquely existentialist
question is it
i mean pindar actually asked this in one
of his owns
what is a person
what is not a person
this is a classic question
existentialists are different
in one respect by focusing on the
concrete existence of the person
of the human being
as the place to start
the locus to begin philosophizing
so rather than beginning by abstracting
away from our
qualities our characteristics our
relationships our history
we begin with that and then we try to
make sense of that which is really how
we live in the world isn't it
do we first begin as philosophers and
you know have a book handed to us well
here's the platonic forms
you know memorize them figure them out
wherever they are here's the universals
or something like that no we're actually
in the situation
and then after we've made some decisions
usually some bad decisions we start
thinking about
what is going on here
what am i what is this person what
how do we relate to each other and we
start to philosophize
so instead of philosophy beginning in
wonder
it begins
with the concrete situation
maybe in anguish
maybe in sorrow maybe enjoyed maybe in
wonder
categories are taken from concrete
existence
it's not just taking it as a starting
point the idea is that philosophy prior
to existentialism was was okay but it
didn't have all the tools all the
conceptual
distinctions
and fundamental you know concepts that
we would need in order to make sense out
of
the things that that concern us the big
philosophical questions like what is the
meaning of life
we would have to get some of those from
our own concrete existence so our the
way in which we live in the world gives
us clues as to
how we ought to conceive of things what
fundamental categories we ought to use
are invoked
one very central theme
in existentialism is freedom
what is it
what is it to be free
is there an essence to freedom
or is it by its very nature
something that can't have an essence
human beings are for all of these these
existentialist thinkers that's one
radical commitment to make human beings
are free we do in fact to some degree
determine our destiny if we don't
control our circumstances we at least
control how we choose to view our
circumstances
so there's a very strong what they call
philosophical libertarian
element to to existentialism and it
pervades all of their their writings and
their thought
how do we use our freedom do we use our
freedom to
throw our freedom away
sart actually had a lot of analyses of
that sort of thing as did uh
camus and
marcel and people like kikergaard
nietzsche as well
or do we use freedom to promote freedom
can you
wrap your head around freedom
those are existentialist things
responsibility goes hand in hand for
them as well
and not in the moralistic kind of sense
like you know well you know great great
power comes great responsibility art
well since you're free you're
responsible you know it will hold you to
high standards or something like that
rather it's an awareness of the
responsibility of the person who
actually has freedom that freedom is in
a certain respect not only liberating
it's awesome
in the classic sense i'm not like you
know super great but uh inspiring us
with a sense of awe dread perhaps even
fear
and that's because of our responsibility
for the existentialists there's a sort
of radical commitment to
nobody can give you the definitive guide
you have to actually do the work of
figuring it out
you have a responsibility and you can't
just go with whatever you like
you can't just say well this suits me so
i'll do it because that's not a
responsible use of freedom instead you
have to actually do some work and think
it out
this is a good point to jump into
another thing
existentialist thought
by its nature is anti-systematic so this
is why it's also hard to pin down
because the existentialists all these
people here
they all rejected at least some sort of
system that was put in front of them as
the
comprehensive
way to understand
metaphysics ethics
human nature
the way we ought to live together all
these sorts of
things um they rejected a systematically
put together set of answers that are
supplied by
something ahead of time something before
getting into concrete situations
whether it be
a philosophy like that of hegel which
grief regard is rejecting
nietzsche is also rejecting in his term
whether it be
an institution
whether it be a set of cultural
assumptions as kierkegaard was in
rejecting what he called chris and dumb
in favor of christianity and nietzsche
was in announcing the death of god
whether it be a political party
whether it be a click whether it be pick
whatever you like
anything that would give you a
comprehensively systematically
articulated set of answers
before you've actually been allowed to
ask questions and not actually
set some of those those answers out
there on the table at risk
existentialists would be against their
anti-systematic in that respect
revolt
rebellion
exercising one's freedom
against the system is very often part of
the existentialists ideas
so that that is a key theme as well
another thing that i particularly like
about it is
is there's great attention
particularly by kierkegaard
by dostoyevsky
by heidegger
and by marcel
but i'm not leaving the others out on
this but those are the ones who really
really stand out
in analyzing not just our intellectual
side not just the side of our action and
commitments
but analyzing our affective side
uh our moods
our
emotions
another term i should put up here our
loves and our hates
our fundamental loves that orient
ourselves
that orient us our desires
those are considered just as important
for philosophy by existentialists and by
by the novelists especially
because you know
just as important as our intellect
because they are part of our concrete
situation
and not just minds but your moods and
other people's moods
the way in which they
color the world
and change its objects
and close enough possibilities for us
and open up other possibilities
that's really central to existentialism
that's one of the contributions i think
they they make in their work
the subjective nature of truth
is another really central component of
existentialism and again this goes back
to the focus on concrete existence
if truth is to matter
it cannot be a purely abstract
objective in the sense of applying to
everybody no matter what condition
they're in no matter what experience
they've had if it's a truth that
actually matters that means something it
has to be a truth that can grip me in my
heart in my guts not just in my my head
that means that it has to be subjective
does this mean that everything goes out
the door and now it's you know everybody
just believes whatever they want the
existentialists don't want to have a
commitment like that they don't want to
say we're all just relativists
but truth being
connected with our subjective situation
there are certain kinds of truths
that we can only know as subjects not as
objects
as through our own involvement in them
not just through
being told about them or reading
something that somebody else has written
about
there are certain types of truth we have
to experience
gabriel marcel talks about this very
well
in in terms of distinguishing what he
calls a problem and a mystery
a problem is something and it can be on
a lot of different levels but a
philosophical problem is something that
we want to try to obtain knowledge about
or some sort of resolution about
and we can look at it as being outside
of ourselves we can step back and it may
in fact be a good thing to do to
distance ourselves from it
a mystery
is a
different kind of problem
in which we are involved in it
so you know what kind of creature am i
if i'm asking myself that question
that's a mystery
what is evil
that's a mystery that's not a problem
that's not a philosophical problem it's
a philosophical mystery
which doesn't mean that we just stop
short and say oh mystery we can't figure
it out
it means that we when we're delving into
it we have to acknowledge that we
actually have a really important role in
not just
the activity of figuring it out but what
we're figuring out we're already out
there in what we're figuring out this is
kind of inexact to say that but maybe
that gives you some understanding
the last thing i'd like to say about
existentialism that i think is
characteristic of it as a philosophical
movement
is that it's not just a philosophical
movement i think that from its very
beginnings and its very heart even in
sort of kierkegaard an event especially
in dostoevsky
the literary
and that covers a lot of ground and the
philosophical are fused together
in ways that are often
beautiful
in ways that are sometimes horrific
and i'm not just talking about kafka
there some of these other authors as
well you know camus the stranger is in
certain sense horrific
as is in a much grander sense the fall
or the plague
kafka definitely so
but also even in kierkegaard
it's not just nietzsche who talks about
you know the abyss and when you look
into the university this looks into you
kierkegaard has that thought too
dostovsky has that part
so you have philosophical ideas
philosophical concepts a philosophical
way of life being fused into poetry
literature
novels short stories
vignettes in sort of kierkegaard's
writings
nietzsche has certain adaptations as
well the diatribe
and also plays gabriel marcel
jean-paul sarge write write plays so
this makes a lot of sense if you think
about this this other theme the focus on
concrete existence is a starting point
because what is the difference between
a novel
in which
somebody
say attempts to live out
descartes meditations and ideas and
descartes meditations itself
the
character if you want to say that there
is one in descartes meditations is a
universal it's an every man it's
it's anybody who's reading it can can
buy into it
a novel places characters
into concrete
existence where there's a history
there's relationships there's events
it's different than just the the ideas
itself
the idea is take on flesh
that's what existentialism does and
that'll be my sort of summary so focus
on concrete existence freedom
focus on responsibility being
anti-systematic
looking to and analyzing our affective
side
truth as subjective and then finally the
connection with literature
that's existentialism